there is a great deal of talk today
about the original intent
of the writers of the constitution now
no matter where one stands on that issue
it is important to realize that the
writers of the constitution
did not foresee or plan to create the
political system that we have today
that is a democratic republic based upon
two
national and permanent political parties
indeed
democracy and political parties with
dirty words to them
nor did the writers anticipate the
economic system we have today
or our social values in many if not most
ways
the world they lived in was very
different from the one we live in
they realized that their world was
likely to change that's one of the
reasons
they put into the constitution the
amendment process
which in turn is one of the major
reasons this document has survived
as our frame of government for so long
and despite
all the changes in all aspects of
american life
now to understand the world of the
founders
we must first understand who they were
the problems they faced
and why they created this new frame of
government
we also need to understand the
historical controversies
that have swirled around them and
exactly what
is in the document that they created
the public lack of knowledge of those
contents
is frightening a survey conducted during
the 1987 bicentennial
showed 46 percent not knowing the
original purpose of the constitution
26 thought it was to declare in the
independence from england
59 did not know what the bill of rights
was
only 41 correctly identified it as the
first 10 amendments
27 thought it was the preamble to the
constitution
and a frightening 49 percent erroneously
thought
the president could suspend the
constitution
let's begin with the world of 1787
and the ensuing historical controversies
the constitution was not the original
frame of government of the newly
independent united states
the states originally were governed by
the second continental congress
and then from 1781 to 1789
by the articles of confederation now
late 19th century historians
saw these articles as a disastrous
failure
and indeed called this time period the
critical period
where an infant and endangered united
states
was saved by the god-like founding
fathers
that interpretation was stood on its
head in the early 20th century
by historians such as charles beard who
argued
that it was not a critical period but
that its democratic thrust
alienated the moderates of the previous
decade the revolutionary decade
who had become reluctant revolutionaries
motivated by economic and class
interests they responded
with the constitution as an
anti-democratic
counter-revolutionary document in an
effort to protect those interests
now that interpretation itself then came
under attack
in the mid and late 20th century this as
we will see in later lectures
is part of the ongoing process of
historical interpretation
and reinterpretation for now let me just
note that many historians today
view the constitution as a continuation
of the revolution
not the antithesis of the revolution
also the issue is far from settled
and it is unlikely ever to be settled
for historical interpretations again as
we will explore in later lectures
are constantly being affected and
revised by present day
concerns my interpretation that follows
will thus reflect contemporary
scholarship and contemporary
issues and values
now the process of creating governments
began in the 1770s as the colonial
assemblies
transformed themselves into state
legislatures and governments
this process would involve a series of
major departures from british practice
reflecting colonial experiences
for example the colonists rejected the
british concept of
balanced government in favor of
overwhelming
legislative power the colonial governors
and judges
had been royal appointees and had been
perceived as tyrannical
in the articles of confederation period
their powers were extremely limited
within
each state you also had a move to
written constitutions within each state
instead of
unwritten constitutions this was due to
the perceived failure
of the unwritten british constitution to
protect liberty
you also had an old tradition in
colonial history
of written charters in the founding of
many colonies
state assemblies became more
representative due to the logic of the
revolution as i explained in the last
lecture
with the franchise extended and frequent
elections
the central government at first was the
second continental congress which was
obviously makeshift
and it was replaced by the articles of
confederation
which were presented to the states in
1777
but not ratified by all the states until
1781.
why the states retained their distrust
of
any centralized power that's what they
were fighting against
and they also retained the distrust of
each other there had been
no history of cooperation before the
revolution
and the cooperation that existed during
the revolutionary period
had been quite limited and broke down
once the revolution ended
smaller states fear larger ones
especially those with western land
claims
for fear that they the small states
would lose their population
to larger states that could avoid taxing
by simply using
land sales to run the government
maryland for example
refused to ratify the articles of
confederation
unless state western land claims were
given
to the national government virginia and
other states agreed in order to get a
central government
and because they believed that a
republican form of government
could not work in large areas this is
something i'll get to later
now the articles did set up a central
government of sorts
but a very weak one there was no
executive no judiciary
only a congress with no power to tax
or to do anything important without a
vote of nine out of the 13 states
nor could they change the structure
without a unanimous
vote in favor of changing it each state
had one vote
and thus a virtual veto power
this had all been done very consciously
the states saw themselves as
independent republics retaining
sovereignty
and joining into a loose confederation
similar to today's united nations this
came
from their colonial past in addition to
their fear of centralized power
from the revolutionary era liberty was
now to be guaranteed
by decentralization and by state
legislatures
now despite the inherent weaknesses
obvious of this frame of government
much was actually accomplished under the
articles
the winning of independence and the
obtaining of a favorable peace treaty in
1783
with a western boundary all the way to
the mississippi river
the establishment of state governments
with many social and political reforms
the lowering of property qualifications
for voting
to extend the franchise frequent
elections
separation of church and state beginning
of the abolition of slavery in northern
states
expansion of education and literacy
and the creation of state bills of
rights
you also established the pattern for
western expansion and settlement
with the northwest ordinances of 1784
85 and 87. all western land
north of the ohio river that had been
given up by the states
to the national government was to be
surveyed
divided and sold in 640 acre lots
for one dollar per acre
eventually there would be self-rule
and admission to the union as
anywhere from three to five new states
on an equal basis
when the population had reached 60 000
there were also guarantees of freedom of
worship
trial by jury and there was to be no
slavery
in this entire territory internationally
trade was opened with the european
powers under the articles of
confederation
and with asia and loans
were extended to the united states
but the problems under the articles
appeared to many to outweigh
these successes by 1787 and those
problems were both
external and domestic
the confederation congress had no power
to tax
and thus no power to pay for an armed
force
or to pay its debts
after the revolution the navy was sold
at one point the army
was down to 80 men rather than a
national army
reliance was placed on untrained and
unreliable
state militia now this
lack of military power lack of powered
attacks
translated into no power in foreign
affairs
and no respect from the european powers
the british locked the united states out
of their mercantilist trading system
they also violated the peace treaty by
refusing to leave
their posts in the northwest and they
supported in fact incited indian
resistance
from those posts to american settlers
nor was that the end of it spain refused
to agree
to the southern u.s boundary with
florida
and denied the united states the right
to navigate the mississippi river
and the right of deposit at new orleans
it also incited secessionist movements
in the southwest internally
there is a post-war economic depression
blamed on the articles
people in each state demand relief the
easiest way to obtain relief
is to stop foreclosures on land for
non-payment of debts
to repudiate debts and or to print
paper money so as to create inflation
which will make repayment of debts much
easier
that is easy to do since there's little
or no check on legislative powers in
each state
and creditors and men of property
complain that the state governments are
breaking the social contract
by doing this and that this is as we
would say today
democracy run amok
states are establishing their own
currencies and trading systems
there's a breakdown in interstate
relations with the looming danger
of states turning to european allies and
thus
opening the door to european
intervention
manipulation and control by 1786-87
there is fear of anarchy with shea's
rebellion
in western massachusetts daniel shays
revolutionary war hero led a march of
1200
on the courts to stop foreclosures and
then
on the springfield arsenal to obtain
weapons
there was no national army to stop this
the state militia did
but they could just as easily have
failed due to lack of training
or even joined shea's men and after
chase's defeat
his followers were elected to office and
stopped foreclosures anyway
what all of this illustrated was the
weakness of both the state governments
and the national government
now all of this convinced many that the
present national government was
incapable of defending the liberty one
during the revolution and that a new
frame of government was necessary
what you have here one needs to realize
is an elite definition of liberty it is
not
democracy at all it is
individual freedom from tyranny
or from any form of external control
or interference but
by the political thought of the day such
tyranny or control
could come from above or from below
from mob rule that broke the social
contract john randolph
of virginia i think summed this up best
in his famous quote
i am an aristocrat i love liberty
i hate equality
now while the revolution has fought
successfully for liberty and against
tyranny from above
liberty to these men is now threatened
by tyranny from below
simultaneously it is once again
threatened by tyranny
from above as well the danger of
european intervention
and the destruction of the entire
republican experiment
more centralized power is thus perceived
as necessary
to fend off the europeans and their
tyranny from above
and the tyranny from below that would
come from democratic mob
rule by 1786
those who think this way find support
amongst the middle and lower classes
as well as the upper classes creditors
of course
merchants and shippers who want a
national commercial policy
and power to break into the european
mercantilist trading systems
artisans who want a high national tariff
westerners who want defense against the
indians the british and the spanish
land speculators wanting the same as
well as protection
from squatters in 1786
representatives from five states met in
annapolis
and asked congress to call a special
convention to revise
and strengthen the articles of
confederation
that would lead to the constitutional
convention
55 men from 12 states gathered in
philadelphia
from may to september 1787.
well who are they it's interesting to
note
who is not in philadelphia such
revolutionary radicals is patrick henry
sam adams thomas jefferson
they are not there the revolutionary
leaders franklin and washington
are present but aside from these two
venerable figures most of the delegates
are quite young james madison and
governor morris
are only 35. rufus king and alexander
hamilton
are only 32. charles pinckney
is only 29. almost
all had continental as opposed to state
experiences during the revolutionary war
many were veterans of washington's
continental army
or the continental congress and that
experience gave them
a national as opposed to a state outlook
at least one historian has labeled them
the first
true americans
now are they conservative or
revolutionary they are simultaneously
both
they are conservative as men of property
who
fear democracy and mar brule as
destructive of liberty
they are elitist republicans if you will
rather than democratic
republicans but simultaneously
they are revolutionary in their desire
to create something new
a large republic with centralized power
that preserves liberty rather than
destroying it one needs to understand
that this contradicts established
political thought and experience
that established political thought and
experience held that republics
only worked in small areas and that
large
centralized nations were best ruled
by absolute monarchs
the founders would turn this on its head
and what you get here one might argue is
a concept of creating
an empire of liberty
the men who gather in philadelphia were
also willing to ignore their
instructions to revise and amend the
articles of confederation
and instead they decided to come up with
an entirely new frame of government
one that they devised in secret sessions
with
locked doors and windows despite the
summer heat
one can argue that in some ways what you
had here
was a coup the basic dilemma
how do you create a government strong
enough to preserve liberty
from tyranny of the mob and or from the
european monarchs
without giving it enough power
to be tyrannical itself
this dilemma was best expressed by the
father of the constitution
james madison later when he wrote
the 51st federalist paper
if men were angels madison wrote
no government would be necessary if
angels were to govern men
neither external nor internal controls
would be necessary
in framing a government which is to be
administered by men
over men the great difficulty lies in
this
you must first enable the government to
control the governed
and in the next place oblige it to
control
itself
a dependence on the people is madison
continued
no doubt the primary control on
government
but experience has taught mankind
the necessity of auxiliary precautions
the constitution thus begins with we
the people sovereignty rests with the
people
but the document then separates
sovereignty from rule
by a series of intermediaries and it
divides
power between those intermediaries so as
to avoid tyranny
we know the system is checks and
balances and it exists on two levels
the separation of powers between the
three branches of the new national
government
and the division of powers between that
new national government
and the existing state governments
let's look at the separation of powers
first the founders returned to the
concept of balanced government
due to the perceived excesses and
weaknesses of the existing legislative
governments
what they decided to do was to combine
elements of monarchy aristocracy
and democracy within the new national
government let's look at the president
the president is a monarch the executive
power
but one indirectly elected
via the electoral college and it was
perceived at that time
that the electors in the electoral
college
would be the aristocrats
furthermore the president's term is
limited to four years
and the powers of the presidency are
limited to those
enumerated in article two of the
constitution
the senate is an aristocratic branch of
government
it is not directly elected by the people
not in the original constitution you
needed a constitutional amendment to
change that
it is done via the state legislatures
one might argue that the people elect
senators indirectly
they vote for their bettors in the state
legislatures
and the state legislatures determine who
will be the senators
the term is lengthy six years with the
powers listed in article one of the
constitution
the national judiciary is also
aristocratic
the democratic branch is to be the house
of representatives
with short terms frequent elections but
still
you have property qualifications for
voting
the theory at the time was that you had
to have a stake
in society in order to be able
to vote each branch
had the power to check the other
branches for example the president is
the commander-in-chief
but congress appropriates funds for the
armed forces and declares war
the president makes judicial and
diplomatic appointments and
negotiates treaties but with the quote
advice and consent of the senate
and appropriations approved by both
houses congress makes the laws
but the president can veto them and the
congress can override the veto
with a two-thirds vote so much for the
separation of powers what about the
division of powers
the new national government has enormous
power but does not have a monopoly on
power
it is to be shared with the existing
state governments
and that is explicitly reaffirmed in the
tenth amendment
which states that all powers not
delegated to the new national government
or prohibited by it to the states
are reserved to the states so that
the states can be capable of checking
the national
government as the national government
can be capable
of checking the excesses of the state
some powers are very clearly shared
state
militia are controlled by the state
governments unless
called into service by the president to
active service
for the national government by the
president
the document sets up a very
large republic as i pointed out before
in theory by political theory of the day
it cannot
survive madison in the 10th federalist
paper
turns this established political theory
on its head
he claims that a republic in a large
area has a
better chance of preserving liberty than
a republic in a small
area and in the process he explains the
logic
behind the entire system
madison defines factions as the key
problem
and factions as a minority or a majority
willing to ride roughshod over the
rights of others
to ensure its own interests in
democracies a majority faction
can easily gain control and destroy
liberty
now madison insists that such factions
cannot be abolished
without abolishing liberty they are
inherent in human nature
the key is to control them and that is
to be done
via checks and balances madison then
argues
that a large republic can do this better
than small
republics because the greater the
population and
area the more factions will exist
and thus the last less chance of one
faction
dominating over the others as madison
noted in this regard
a major difference between a republic
and a democracy
was the greater number of citizens and
the extent of territory
that could exist under a republican
government
the smaller the society madison wrote
the fewer probably will be the distinct
parties and interests composing it
the fewer the distinct parties and
interests the more frequently will a
majority be found of the same party
and the smaller the number of
individuals composing a majority
and the smaller the compass with in
which they are placed
the more easily will they consert and
execute their plans
of oppression that's her small
democratic society
as for republics extend the sphere
and you take in a greater variety of
parties and interests
you make it less probable that a
majority of the whole will have a common
motive
to invade the rights of other citizens
or if such a common motive exists
it will be more difficult for all who
feel it
to discover their own strength and to
act in unison
with each other now despite
agreement on such essentials
disagreements among the delegates almost
wrecked the convention
major disputes pit large against small
states northern against southern states
delegates also split over just how much
power to give
to the national government at the
expense of the states
the large versus small state dispute
focuses on representation in congress
madison's virginia plan had called for
representation in both houses of
congress
to be based on population small states
like new jersey refused to agree the
result was the so-called
great compromise the house of
representatives would be based on
population
but there would be equal representation
for all states in the senate
there is also a split between commercial
and urban
the commercial and urban north as
opposed to the agrarian and slave
holding south
that split was already apparent and it
led to a series of compromises
there would never be an export tax
because the south produced the cash crop
there would be no ban on the slave trade
for 20 years
a two-thirds vote would be needed in the
senate on all treaties
and a slave was to count as three-fifths
of a person
for purposes of representation and
taxation
now some delegates fear that despite the
checks and balances this new national
government had too much power
only 39 of the 55 who were in attendance
signed the final document but the
majority believed they had come up with
something superior and unique
a large centralized republic
capable of acting strongly while
preserving
liberty but will their fellow
citizens agree the document called for
special state ratifying conventions in
each state
with nine states needed to put the
document into effect
intense opposition emerges virtually
every state primarily from established
groups who control state governments
and fear such centralized power the
result would be a major struggle in each
state it was very close
especially in the critical states of
virginia and new york
the federalist papers i quoted were
written not only by madison but also by
alexander hamilton and john jay in an
effort to convince
new york voters to accept the
constitution
the pro-constitution forces won for a
host of reasons
they were better organized they were on
the offensive
and they had the advantage of defining
themselves as federalists
really they were nationalists but by
taking the title federalists
what could their opponents call
themselves anti-federalists that was
quite a negative
connotation also the call for
ratification
via state conventions special state
conventions meant that the state
legislatures which had a vested interest
in the failure of the new system would
be bypassed
furthermore the federalists agreed to a
key anti-federalist objection
the lack of any specific bill of rights
they agreed to create one as their first
order of business
under the new government the result
would be the first ten amendments to the
constitution
north carolina and rhode island did not
agree until 1790-91
but the rest did agree early enough for
the new government to begin functioning
in 1789.
what do we have here the final document
in the federalist papers
showed the founders as hobsian realists
who distrusted human nature
and who sought to stop what they
considered the excesses of the
revolution
in that sense they could be considered
conservative
and even counter revolutionary
simultaneously however
they are still lockheens and
revolutionaries who wish to preserve
their republican experiment
against what they consider clear and
present dangers
and they are willing to try a radical
unprecedented experiment
to do so the only analogy they have for
a large
republic is rome
and that is not a very reassuring
one they see their constitution
as fulfilling not negating the ideas of
the declaration of independence
a way to make republicanism work and
thereby
allow liberty to thrive now they succeed
in establishing a new frame of
government
but in the process they left a series of
unanswered questions for the future
is this a union of the people is the
house
shows or of the states as the senate
shows what is the proper balance between
state and national power
how can you have a republican empire of
liberty when that liberty
is based on the enslavement of others
counting slaves as three-fifths of a
human being
does not really answer that question and
can you really have an empire of liberty
a large expanding nation run by a
central government
powerful enough to retain domestic order
and military security
without creating a tyranny from above
within a few years the writers of this
document will split on their answers to
these questions
they will fail to resolve them in their
lifetimes they will change the system
they created
in trying to solve them and they will
bequeath those problems to their
successors
and while some of those problems would
be resolved in the 19th century
be it by compromise or by civil war
others remain central
to our political discourse without
throughout the 20th century
and still today most notably the proper
balance between state and national power
and some would argue whether it is
indeed possible to have
an empire of liberty
[Music]
you